last time I was on this podcast I was
talking about the Australian accent we
were talking about how there's that R
sound that Americans hear and somebody
went viral duetting me cuz I was on the
podcast saying do Australians hear the r
sound that they're saying at the end of
no and this girl duet me and she's like
this nor
aound and uh you're sitting there like
yes there is what did the comments say
like well she just did it no she wasn't
doing it it just made it actually made
me analyze it and be like yeah it makes
sense it's like there's not an R sound
but we're hearing one and if you let it
that can help you kind of figure out the
accent but it's it's it makes sense
they're going there's no R sound we're
going yes there is and that that tension
is where the accent Liv cuz it seems
like I mean correct me if I'm wrong but
it seems like when they go no it's like
the back of their tongue coming up nor
exactly nor which can sound like an R
yeah it can but I realized like there's
two dude are watching Love Island games
by the way no oh my [__] god do they
kill each other in this one yeah dude
it's fight to the death Hunger Games
it's [__] so the people get that get
eliminated are actually dead so
they could you imagine could you imagine
dude yeah we have said this before but
imagine it's like 16 Islanders compete
for true love if you get
eliminated just fold them right in front
of the cast yeah no they fight each
other that's cuz that's what it is it's
like the
um my god oh yeah it's like that it's
like some capsule inside their head oh
it's such a
good yeah anyway so what's the games
well it's funny because it like your
fate in the house is less decided by
like you know the people at home or
whether or not you're coupled up I'm
sorry they just put a sniper scope on
that dude's head can we run that right
into our hand they dude they put a
sniper scope on that dude's head
yeah it's kind of like it's kind of it's
kind of like squid games you know where
there just like hella like producers
with guns on the outskirts they're like
oh I'm getting him yeah no it's like
basically they face off like this okay
like they challenge like they you know
if you lose the games that's when you
can get evicted interesting so yeah the
Australian people have like a weird
accent that's not the or oh it's not the
sandard
[__] yeah [__] [__] ban you
think it is I don't know I don't don't
quote me on that yeah apparently you
know cuz I do this Australian accent
that people like and in Australia it
often goes viral because people go what
this guy isn't Australian I was just
watching this video and I didn't
understand what why people were saying
it was crazy and then I realized this
guy's not Australian he's American
that's so wild but apparently I'm doing
some specific Australian accent and I
don't know what that is they're like oh
yeah yeah this is exactly from this
place and it's this guy and I'm like is
it I didn't know
that what area it's like if somebody
does a perfect American accent but
they're doing a Southern accent you're
like that's the perfect southern accent
and they're like oh I just thought I was
doing an americ what the hell yeah
that's how you sound them Alabama the
mother I say it to
him yeah I don't P that I say it
to that's how you sound actually there's
this really funny Tik Tok of this I
think it's a Chinese guy
saying like he can't speak English but
it's like him saying what English sounds
like to him oh hell so it sounds like
he's really close to speaking English
but he's not saying real words right
right right awesome well you didn't
finish so you're watching the love
Island games which is just like oh just
the Australian accents reminded me of it
cuz the people on the show have just a
weird accent that I've never heard are
the games good though is it like naked
American Ninja Warrior or is it kind of
no they're kind of the same as they
always have been they're just more
competitive got it so like they did the
one where you like spit fluid into the
other person's mouth and then you try to
fill up a jar but everyone's competing
against each other so it's like you're
trying to fill up the other person's jar
yeah pistan we
have ocar we have to the r launcher
fairing aling a people 3500 B that's
crazy isn't that awesome that's what are
these dudes are they like Turkish or
they are out in the mountain they're
from Pakistan 35 onto the boat wow I
love where they are they are just out in
chilling they're like on Brokeback
Mountain or
something those guys are
together speaking of being gay I was I
was um in bed with a man last night
sleeping totally PE